hello mind welcome to this video playing
grandma Zach a storm that's rude regal
vasquez Schroeder from Chile yes i
remember playing him i had some chicken
run against him ok now he avoids that ok
I'm going for some different setup here
with g6 interesting change of change of
setup um still why not be five going
back okay rook e8 doesn't look too bad
right now let's stop any Oh Bishop g5
wasn't threatening interesting it's a
little bit like some kind of some kind
of brea so i cannot get in see for now
so 12 okay maybe I'm just shutting it
down let's see how to play here
difficult to get in to get in f5 p.m.
that's quite unlikely to happen
you
and I wonder if I can manage to trade
the dark squared bishop it's also not
very likely to work yeah I cannot do
much here frankly it's not very active
remove order wasn't and wasn't great i
guess i'm happy about that now I get the
rooks traded makes life a little bit
easier in the long run yeah that that
I'm very happy about I remember that
game that we had once in the closed Roy
he had tone he made no progress
whatsoever and was winning on time at
the end after check oh yeah so it's very
weird what he say why is he giving me
the fr it's quite strange threatening
mate it's always funnier threatening
mate so I can check here Queen age 84
King g8 what are you doing against that
mr. Schroeder again he can block the
first rancor but it's still a funny move
to play I just wanted to play it because
of it look it looks just loose looks
just great which we have six was a good
move of course but that it just looks
funny
and we can close look at b1 for example
now or this one so check check ok I have
to be a little bit cautious now that i'm
not at the end giving him the a file
this is something that I should avoid
actually so I'm just going to go back
here have no idea what is doing
absolutely no idea
yeah no I'm starting to get optimistic
here to be honest Bishop over to e7 28
how is he keeping that porn
I just have to what to lose on time this
is exactly what happened in the in the
game that I had against him it's been a
while gen-y go it he was he wasn't
really getting anywhere and at some
point I was just it was just I was
stepping the time okay mmm that's
interesting actually maybe he gets in d5
interesting 2427 because e 5 is giving
away the pawn on d5 so it's not so easy
to do
and maybe I can try to enter here right
with Queen a 1 now interesting okay
maybe this has has some merit what he's
done I didn't understand any of it
really thinking it is just just bad
again I don't understand anything I it's
made their it's not just g6 ah bad bad
bad black resins Kim did I was be
interesting i didn't understand any of
it i don't think it was as wasn't any
good what he did to be honest and i will
be having people claiming that i always
claimed a better blah blah blah but yeah
I'm it's minus 1 point 4 according to
the comp because this is just reek what
he has I did something badly him what
did I do wrong f4 Queen a oneness
winning okay hmm no and he I had time
bed time came
yeah all kinds of stuff is hanging him
Queen see one is the engine and then f6
why this is going to explode him with
his weird pieces and the way it went
check what about this Queen a one still
wins and now white is better huh tough
that stuff there was just one moment
that Queen a one that total review did
what he did and he f6 also what was
pretty strong Aaron Queen h8 was a
little bit of a show-off move you played
many a strange thing shadows game
avoiding trades where he should have
traded blah blah blah term and all this
is pretty awful actually f 3g form you
might just must just have to punish it
and I didn't check I Queen a one that's
just the thing you have to have to see
that move that I'm activating now what I
didn't see is really that I'm not
getting yeah this is after this own I'm
not getting um any further I'm not
making any progress here against this
position is keeping this and yeah I mean
it's still the engine gives equal still
and here i can just take g5 why didn't I
do that I am such an idiot sometimes and
after this he can still just resign the
game what am i doing now stupid very
stupid and now why this better yeah and
sometimes it's just crazy what I'm
giving away Bishop g6 was was winning
and now now we saw it finally
I had to really play some atrocious
moves to lose the game and I managed and
clean edge to what a joke I can just
take this there's nothing what is
absolutely nothing there I don't
understand what I'm doing sometimes yeah
so I think out of the opening I'm
slightly worse but he played a couple of
quite strange decisions taking on on
before it's just a mistake it trades
pieces and then he started to
systematically week in his position yeah
giving me the a file and yeah okay I
have to stop this otherwise I'm renting
too much yeah we basically did
everything to lose the game and I just
didn't didn't take that point as I
should have done okay thanks for
watching